hygrophila everyone this is a Bobby
Gupta representing mahindra satyam I'm
the vice president and head out for
Middle East Africa and Turkey so I think
a warm welcome to everyone this has been
a great experience to be here as a part
of the delegate what we heard this
morning from his majesty king of the
last page and the prime minister of
Libya Iraq our delegates it's a it's
important for all of us to think of the
ways how we can improve the job creation
in the in the Middle East I said we
heard the figures of 85 million people
hitting jobs in next 10 years time so
whether like it's a combination of jobs
being created by the public sector by
the private sector or SMEs but the real
question for all of us is how we can
work together in a collaborative way to
get their mass audience a message yes we
do care for you it's not a question of
lip service but ESB as industry we as
the government we as a private citizens
do care proper buzzer sisters I was
unless and until we create opportunities
throughout the Middle East people you
will see a brain drain so how we can
reverse the brain drain and get people
was be whoever being overseas local
arabic speaking people to bring them
back that means we need to have the
higher improper jobs in the IT industry
in the government sector in the private
sector to attract people to come back to
arab countries and secondly is V as a
private sector working hand in hand of
the government sector to create jobs but
unless or until we look for
opportunities for the Arab citizens this
region won't go it can only grow when we
create jobs for the people in the region
thank you